[Music]  what happens when two very different  people move in together and still can't  pay the rent until they find two lovely  ladies who also need a place to call  home  who have long term boyfriends who now  basically live there and one of them has  a cute runaway nephew while another's  parents lost everything and have to move  on in with of course their beloved dog  Harley who refuses to go anywhere  without his favorite mailman put them  all under one roof and you've got  roomies the most outrageous roommate  comedy and oh damn I forgot about the  hard-partying guys across the hall who  were evicted and lived there now - as  does the building maintenance man a  convict trying to turn his life around  his parole officer who doesn't believe  in him and a character who might be from  the game of Thrones and introducing Fred  Willard  [Applause]  on TBS I think we're gonna need a bigger  couch  [Applause]  you